hey this is presh talwalkar
i want to thank mike painter for
emailing me this problem which comes
from a 1957 math class
a man is standing due east of a tower
and notes it subtends an angle of 45
degrees with the tower
he walks south 42.4 feet and the
subtended angle is 30 degrees
how tall is the tower
note the subtended angle is from the
ground to the top of the tower
remember this problem is from 1957 so
you can only use pencil and paper
no calculators are allowed
but you can refer to whatever was
commonly available in 1957
like trade tables slide rules etc
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
so what's so amazing about this problem
is the man can estimate the tower's
height without knowing the distance to
the base of the tower
this is useful if the tower's base is
inaccessible say because the tower is
protected by a wall or surrounded by a
moat
and all we need is a little geometry
in particular we'll use some properties
of right triangles
we'll use the 45-45-90 isosceles right
triangle
in this case both of the legs have the
same length
we'll also use the 30-60-90 right
triangle
in this case if the leg opposite 30
degrees is y
the leg opposite 60 degrees will be y
times the square root of 3.
finally we'll use the pythagorean
theorem
if we have a right triangle with legs of
a and b then its hypotenuse will be the
square root of the quantity a squared
plus b squared
so the man is standing
east of the tower and he subtends a 45
degree angle with the tower
so we'll assume that the tower is
perpendicular to the ground
and we have an angle of 45 degrees from
the man
this creates an isosceles right triangle
a 45 45 90 right triangle
so if the tower's height is h
we can then use the property of this
right triangle to get that the other leg
of the tower will also be h so the
distance from the man to the tower is
also the same length as the height of
the tower
now the man walks south 42.4
feet
so we'll visualize this
the man is walking south
this will be at a right angle
so we end up with another right triangle
we know that one leg is h
because that's the distance from before
then the other leg will be 42.4 feet
because that's the distance the man
walked
so we can then calculate the distance
from the man to the tower using the
pythagorean theorem
so the distance from the man to the
tower will be the square root of h
squared plus 42.4 squared
we finally have one more right triangle
to consider
from this position the subtended angle
to the tower is 30 degrees
so this creates one more right triangle
the subtended angle is 30 degrees so the
other angle is 60 degrees so we have a
30 60 90 right triangle
so let me just rotate this diagram so
it's a little easier to see
we know that the leg opposite 30 degrees
is h
and the leg opposite 60 degrees is the
square root of the quantity h squared
plus 42.4 squared
so how tall is the tower
well we can use the property of the 30
60 90 right triangle
that the leg opposite 30 degrees if that
length is y then the leg opposite 60
degrees is square root of 3 times that
from our diagram we end up with the
equality that the square root of h
squared plus 42.4 squared will be equal
to h times the square root of 3.
we then square both sides of the
equation
then we collect the h squared terms and
then we solve for this equation knowing
that the height has to be a positive
quantity
we end up that the height of the tower
is equal to 21.2 times the square root
of two which is approximately
29.98 feet
and we figured out how tall the tower is
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions if you like this video
you can check out my books which are
listed in the video description and you
can support me on patreon if you have a
math topic you can email me presh
mindyourdecisions.com and you can catch
me on social media either at mind your
decisions or at presh tallwalker